ustedes pero podría encaminarse a tener
su sexto presidente en cinco años el
congreso decide se inicia un proceso de
destitución en contra del presidente
pedro castillo por incapacidad moral que
argumentan en una supuesta financiación
irregular del partido que lo llevó al
poder el tráfico de influencias y por
generar inestabilidad económica dominado
por la derecha se necesitarán 52 votos
de los 130 legisladores para darle
inicio al juicio político hasta el
momento los partidos derechistas avanza
país renovación popular y el de la
excandidata keiko fujimori fuerza
popular formaron un bloque con el que se
prevee que consigan 43 votos todavía
insuficientes pero incluso congresistas
de su propio partido no descartaron
apoyar el proceso de iniciarse el juicio
político castillo deberá defender su
inocencia en una sesión especial y el
proceso pasará a una segunda instancia
en la que se necesitarán 87 votos para
destituirlo la nueva incertidumbre
política se siente en las calles de lima
la capital creo que todas
inestabilidad en el gobierno que de
alguna forma nos afectan y más ahora con
esta vacancia cuantos presidentes hemos
tenido en estos últimos tiempos bastante
solo que ahora estoy responsabilidad el
presidente ya tiene varios meses y
todavía no nos ha podido como te digo
como como te digo no ofrecer un gabinete
estable que dé soluciones estables a los
problemas económicos que ya venimos
arrastrando
el proceso se da en un momento tenso en
perú tocado por las protestas que
afectan el sector del cobre y la
investigación de la fiscalía sobre la
corrupción de sus ayudantes un panorama
por el que la popularidad de castillo ha
caído a un 25 por ciento